it has arrived the fans have reacted how
did you react to all the response you
saw when stranger things season four
became the most ever watched premiere in
netflix history it feels like i've been
living in a different universe for the
last week and a half it's very strange
um
i i've said this a few times to
different people but we make something
in a bubble you know we don't think
about what people are going to think
about it because we've got to be so
present and so to hand it over is a very
like terrifying experience it's it's
it's weird and odds and nothing that's
happening at the moment is normal you
know you are wonderfully terrifying um
the internet cannot get over your
transformation into vector what was the
hair and makeup process like for you
because i heard there wasn't actually
much cgi right no it's about 10 cgi 90
practical effects yeah so barry gower
who um you know made the night king and
has worked on the witcher um designed uh
with his team duncan john and pat fode
all these great people in england the
wechner suit they took you know i did a
body cast and all that kind of stuff and
then the prosthetics take about seven
and a half hours to put on um yeah so
we'd start at like three
where were you at mentally during
not not where i am today let me tell you
that much in a very different space
how do you get through that
meditation helps i mean it's also good
because i was in character you know and
and like diving deeper into it i used to
play like a little like really dark
music and um listen to weird stuff so
yeah it was good i i heard you were so
incredible you actually made millie
bobby brown cry on set
that could be true how did the other
cast react to you on set
equally as terrified equally as
terrified yeah um sadie it's funny like
sadie in episode four spoiler alert for
those who haven't seen it so
turn off um or you'll edit this out um
uh sadie and episode 4 and vec now
obviously have uh have a bit of a heads
off and and and she
wins in that moment so
there was always a level of strength
that was coming from her whereas with
some of the others they were very
helpless and and and had to be scared
and i just kind of amped that up for
them yeah
do you try to joke a little between
takes like it's just me
sometimes it depends um it depends on
what's going on really it depends on
if i feel like we've got what we needed
and we're sort of just getting extra
bits
and and then
yeah it really depends i mean
yeah i'll talk more about other parts of
it later on when when the whole show's
out yeah well the internet is loving the
what's your vechna song trend right now
so what would your song be well i've
answered this question already so i have
to i have to say the same thing now
which is annoying um
placebo did a cover of kate bush's uh
running up that hill so it would be that
or if i'm being naughty it's miley cyrus
party in the usa always be naughty yeah
you're welcome and of course i have to
ask what can you tease for volume two
what can the fans expect uh you know i
can't give away much but what i can say
is that if you thought it had reached
the limit of what was possible for this
show
there's more to go there's more to come
yeah it gets bigger and scarier and
wilder yeah emotional for you guys to
wrap it all down yeah i cried
yeah i cried on the last day in front of
everyone and i was i was in vecna and
like i've been so like in it and then
all of a sudden rappers called and
i just like thanked everybody and just
burst into tears yeah it was really
awesome
i said you know it's not very cool to
see a monster cry
a lot of crying
yeah
yeah yeah i think so i mean i think we
all we all felt this you know the vector
stuff is is
such a lot of work you know from
everyone involved and i think we all
felt this collective sigh of like
we we did it like we got it and that's
really special it's special to share
that with people
[Music]
you